[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
nuevamente está con nosotros en el
estudio ángela blandón daniela qué
importancia económica tiene esta
reanudación del envío de granos desde
ucrania pues lo primero y lo más
importante raúl es que se va a permitir
la circulación de unos 22 millones de
toneladas de grano que están atrapadas
en este país invadido desde el 24 de
febrero en ese entonces antes de esa
fecha ucrania estaba exportando hasta 6
millones de toneladas de grano por mes
para hacerse una idea de lo importantes
que son estos dos países como despensas
de alimentos no solamente ucrania
también rusia hay que decir que antes de
la guerra entre los dos eran
responsables de una tercera parte de la
exportación de trigo en el mundo también
de una quinta parte de la de maíz y de
un 80 por ciento de las ventas externas
ante aceite de girasol inclusive esta
empresa ningún león que es la mayor
compañía de comercio de grano del país y
cuyo propietario y si joe murió en un
bombardeo ruso exportó en 2021 un
recorte de 564 millones toneladas de
productos agrícolas a un total de 38
países ahora el mercado raúl ya está
reaccionando a la noticia los precios de
estos insumos empezaron a bajar este
lunes del valor del trigo y del maíz cae
más o cerca del 3% inició la jornada un
poquito más bajo pero ya está bajando
inclusive hasta el 3% raúl bueno una
buena noticia a danny y cambiamos de
información porque aunque quería
prescindir del carbón alemania ha sido
obligada a reanudar el uso de estas
plantas debido a los cortes de gas ruso
bueno se dice que el gobierno alemán ya
reactivó una primera planta de carbón
que se encontraba en situación de
reserva y ahora su producción será
exclusiva para el consumo eléctrico y es
que este país quiere irse alejando poco
a poco de las energías fósiles pero con
una guerra en curso le va a ser muy
difícil entonces qué van a hacer con el
gas pues con miras a que los alemanes
puedan utilizar la calefacción y también
otros electrodomésticos durante el
invierno el poco suministro que les está
llegando por medio del gasoducto nord
stream 1 desde rusia se va a conservar
en depósitos a ser utilizado en esa
época de invierno con esta decisión el
ministerio de economía de ese país se
trazó como meta tener un 75 por ciento
de reserva para inicios de septiembre y
un 95 por ciento para noviembre mientras
tanto lo que también hay que decir raúl
es que este país está mirando qué
naciones pueden suplir sus necesidades
de carbón ahora que está retomando esta
era del carbón para
generar energía y colombia es uno de
ellos pues tiene la mina a cielo abierto
de carbón más grande de américa latina
que es el cerrejón útil y ubicado en la
guajira colombiana una integrante del
parlamento alemán estuvo en esta mina en
la guajira esta es propiedad de la suiza
glencore y en la diputada expresó
algunas preocupaciones entre ellas por
ejemplo que la operación consume 24
millones de litros de agua por día en
una región en la que gran parte de la
población carece de agua potable y de
otros servicios públicos
la mina tiene un impacto significativo
en la región en términos de suministro
de agua potable y también de
contaminación del aire la empresa minera
por supuesto me dice que todo está
perfecto y que lo tiene bajo control
pero durante nuestra visita no hicieron
explotación por lo que intentan que todo
quede perfecto pero como soy una
aficionada del tema conozco la
diferencia de frend danny cambiamos de
tema porque el desempleo en la unión
europea se mantuvo estable en junio pero
si sube en la población juvenil sí señor
pues la oficina de estadísticas del
bloque comunitario eurostat informó que
en este mes de junio la tasa de
desocupación quedó en 6 por ciento es
decir
12,9 millones de personas carecen de
trabajo en la zona comunitaria siendo
españa grecia e italia de nuevo los de
las tasas más altas españa y grecia
tienen más del 12% en los en estos casos
y el 8,1 por ciento de desempleo en
italia pero si vamos más detalladamente
al desempleo juvenil la tasa es más que
se duplica frente al desempleo en
general se ubica 6% que equivale a 25
millones de menores de 25 años que están
sin trabajo en este grupo de 27 países
como se observa en este gráfico durante
la recesión económica mundial de 2008
2009 al menos una cuarta parte de los
jóvenes en esta región quedó sin empleo
desde entonces la cifra comenzó a bajar
hasta que llegó la pandemia la pandemia
también
comenzó a ponerse en un 20 por ciento
alrededor ahora está mucho más bajo el
desempleo juvenil sin embargo vuelve a
tomar una senda alcista indicadores
económicos daniela raúl las bolsas
asiáticas se cerraron en positivo a
pesar de la divulgación de datos
industriales de china que demuestran que
su actividad manufacturera creció menos
de lo esperado en julio también hubo
malos datos al respecto en producción
manufacturera provenientes de europa
aunque las bolsas se comportan al alza y
esto después de que wall street end se
fortaleciera el viernes pasado
justamente hablando del viernes pasado
raúl sabemos que cerró mes fue el último
día bursa y la última sesión bursátil de
julio que fue mejor mes de wall street
desde noviembre de 2020 vemos como sus
principales índices ganaron entre un 7%
y un 12% aunque en lo corrido del año
siguen acumulando pérdidas hoy wall
street abrió ligeramente a la baja
veremos cómo se comporta también este
mes de agosto y que nos trae como cifra
el día 47 % que han caído de los precios
de la vivienda en abril desde abril
hasta lo que vamos del año en sidney en
australia este es el segundo mercado
inmobiliario más caro después de hong
kong y es que los ahorros que tenía la
gente desde la pandemia y también los
cheques de estímulo que vinieron con la
crisis sanitaria ayudaron a aumentar los
precios de la vivienda en todo el país
en un 25 por ciento solamente en 2021
estaban en una especie de burbuja
inmobiliaria ahora los compradores están
desanimando raúl porque las tasas de
interés están mucho más altas y pues
éstas son las que justamente buscan
desincentivar el consumo y bajar los
precios y hablando de tasas altas tasas
altas por toda la región chile las va a
subir en septiembre según piensan
colombia la ciudad 9 % el viernes pasado
9 por ciento es una cifra que no se veía
hace muchos años no recuerdo bien hace
cuánto pero siempre las alzas en colom
han estado entre el 2 el 3 % y ahora
están en 9 dan y le pregunto ya para
finalizar digamos estas tasas si pueden
bajar en algún momento en algún punto
pueden bajarlo digamos como el dólar que
cuando sube y alcanzó un piso pues no
vuelve a bajar digamos
significativamente es más fácil que
bajen las tasas de interés a que baje el
dólar porque como usted recordará esto
es una medida que tiene los bancos
centrales para frenar la inflación en la
medida en que vayan viendo que se están
que los resultados efectivamente están
teniendo efecto valga la redundancia
entre los ciudadanos pues es posible que
las tasas sigan bajando opción en sus
momentos de crisis también las tasas han
estado arriba y pero vemos en el caso de
colombia cómo bajaron bajar bajaron y
ahora están volviendo a subir pero yo
personalmente sí creo que la medida en
que vayan viendo que los precios están
más bajos pues esto también
a alentar al banco de la república a
decirlo lo que buscan es enfriar un poco
la economía pero cuando ya se coló mina
esté fría por así decirlo pues tienen
que bajar las tasas para fomentar el
consumo así es danny como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica le damos paso a
las mentes para